does the cia and the federal government
have interest in ufos
in my experience at cia that is
an area that remains very compartmented
and that could be
one of two reasons it could be because
there is significant interest and that's
why it's so heavily compartmented
or it could be because it's an area
that's non
it's just not important it's a it's a
distraction so they compartment it so it
doesn't
distract from other operations
um one of the areas that i've
been
quite interested in and where i've done
a lot of research and i've done some
work in the private intelligence and
private investigation side is with ufos
the place where ufos really connect with
the federal government is when it comes
to aviation safety
and predominance of power
so
faa and the u.s air force and the u.s
military are very invested in knowing
what's happening in the skies above the
united states
and that's of primary interest to them
when they can rule out
the direct threat to national security
of ufos then they become less interested
that said
when you have unexplained aerial
phenomenon
that are unexplained
that
can't directly be tied to
uh to anything that is known of the
terrestrial world
then they they're left without an answer
to their question they don't know if
it's a threat or not a threat uh but i
think the scarier concern for the u.s
national government or for the us
federal government the scarier concern
that nobody talks about is what if the
ufo isn't alien what if it is actually
a
cutting-edge
war machine that we are eons behind ever
being able to replicate or
the other concern is that it's a
it's a system it's a machine from a
foreign power that's doing intelligence
collection correct so it's not just
military purposes it's actually
collecting data well they fall
a lot of times the federal government
will see the two is the same it's a
hostile tool from a
foreign is is a hostile act absolutely
that's why the espionage act exists
that's why it's a criminal offense if
you're committing espionage in the
united states as a u.s citizen or a
foreign citizen
so i guess they keep digging until they
can confirm it's not a threat but it
just
and you're saying that there's not from
your understanding much evidence that
they're doing so it could be because
they're
compartmentalized
but you're saying private intelligence
um
institutions are
trying to to make progress on this
yeah it's really difficult to know uh
there's a vested yeah there's an
economic interest in the private invest
in the private intelligence world
because for example if you understand
why certain aerial phenomenon are
happening over a location
then
you can use that to inform investors
whether to invest in that location or
avoid investment in that location but
that's not a national security concern
so that doesn't it doesn't matter to the
federal government
could these ufos be aliens now i'm going
into territory of you as a human being
wondering about all the alien
civilizations that are out there
the hum the humbling question
we are not alone
you think we're not alone there's it's
an improbability
that we are alone if by virtue of the
fact that sentient human life exists
intelligent human life exists
all the probabilities that would have to
be destroyed for that to be true
simply speak over the galaxies that
exist that there's no possible way we're
alone it's a mathematical equation it's
a it's a one or a zero right and for me
it has to exist
it's impossible otherwise rationally for
me to think that we are truly the only
intelligent life form in all of the
universe but
to think that
an alien life form is anything like us
at all
is equally as
inconceivable
to think that they're carbon-based
bipedal humanoid
alien species that just happen to fly
around in metal machines
and visit alien planets in a way that
they become observed
is
uh it's just silly it's the world of
sci-fi well
every good scientist
because we always assume that they're
superior to us in intelligence yes when
any scientist carries out an experiment
the whole objective of the experiment is
to observe without
being disclosed or being discovered yeah
so why on earth would we think that the
superior species makes the mistake of
being discovered over and over again
so to push back on that idea if we were
to think about us humans trying to
communicate with ants
first we observe for a while there'll be
a bunch of phds written a bunch of
people just sort of collecting data
taking notes trying to understand about
this
thing that you detected that seems to be
a living thing which is a very difficult
thing to define from an alien
perspective or from our perspective if
we find life on mars or something like
that okay so you observe for a while
but then if you want to actually
interact with it how would you interact
with the ants if i were to interact with
the ants i would try to
uh infiltrate
i would try to put like
figure out what is the language they
used to communicate with each other
uh i would
try to operate at their physical scale
like uh in terms of the physics of their
interaction in terms of the
information methods mediums of
information exchange with pheromones or
whatever however the heck ants so i
would try to mimic them in some way so
in that sense it makes sense
that
um
the objects we would see
you mentioned bipedal yes of course it's
ridiculous that aliens would actually be
very similar to us but maybe they create
forms in order to be like
here uh the the the humans will
understand it and this needs to be
sufficiently different from humans to
know that there's something weird i
don't know i i i think it's actually an
incredibly difficult problem of figuring
out how to communicate with a thing way
dumber than you
people assume like
if you're smart it's easy to talk to the
dumb thing but i think it's actually
extremely difficult when the
gap in intelligence is just orders of
magnitude
and so of course you can observe
but once you notice the thing is
sufficiently interesting
how do you communicate with that thing
so this is where
one of the things i always try to
highlight is how conspiracies are born
because
many people don't understand how easy it
is to fall into the conspiratorial
cycle
so the first step to a conspiracy being
born is to have an a
piece of evidence that is true
and then immediately following the true
evidence is a gap in information
and then to fill in the gap of
information
people
create an idea
and then
the next logical outcome is based on the
idea that they just created which is an
idea that's based on something that was
imaginated in the first place
so the idea the factual thing is now two
steps away and then three steps away
four steps away as the things go on and
then all of a sudden you have this
kernel of truth that turned into this
wild conspiracy
so in in our example
you talked about humans trying to
communicate with ants ants are not
intelligent
there's no ants are not intelligent
species they're drone species that's
somehow commanded through whatever
technology whatever whatever spoken like
a typical human but yes whatever
biological thing is in the queen right
but they're they're not it's not a fair
equivalent but let's look at gorillas or
let's look at something in the monkey
family right where where largely we
agree that there there is some sort of
intelligence there or dolphins some sort
of intelligence right
it is a human thing a human thing to
want to observe
and then communicate
and integrate
that's a human thing not an intelligent
life thing so for us to even think that
a foreign and intelligent alien species
would want to engage and communicate at
all
is an extremely human
assumption
and then from that assumption then we
started going into all the other things
you said if they wanted to communicate
wouldn't they want to mimic if they
wanted to mimic wouldn't they create
devices like ours so now we're three
steps removed from the true fact of
there's something unexplainable in the
skies
yeah so the the fact is there's
something unexplainable in the skies and
then we're cons we're filling in the
gaps with all of our basic human biases
and assumptions exactly but the thing is
now we're getting right back to project
northwood
we need some plan i don't care how crazy
the idea is guys give me some plan so
that's where we come up with well maybe
it's an alien species trying to
communicate or maybe it's an alien
a hostile threat that's trying to take
over the uh the world or who knows what
maybe it's i mean but you have to
uh
you have to somehow construct hypotheses
and theories uh for anomalies
and then
from that
amidst giant pile of the ridiculous
emerges perhaps a deeper truth
absolutely over over a period of decades
and
and uh at first that truth is ridiculed
and then it's accepted you know that
whole
the process um the earth revolving
around the sun yeah the earth revolving
around the sun and but you know to me
it's interesting because it asks
us
looking out there with seti just looking
for alien life
is
forcing us to really ask questions about
ourselves about what is life how special
first of all what is intelligence how
special is intelligence in the cosmos
and i think it's it's uh inspiring and
challenging to us as human beings
both on a
scientific and engineering level but
also on a philosophical level i mean all
those questions are laid before us when
you start to think about alien life so
you you interviewed joe rogan recently
yeah and he said something that i
thought was really really brilliant
during the podcast interview he said
that he's going to love hearing that
very good sorry but he he said that he
realized at some point
that the turn in his opinion about ufos
happened when he realized
how desperately he wanted it to be true
this is
the human condition
we our pink matter works the same way as
everybody's pink matter and one of the
ways that our pink matter works is with
this thing with what's known as a
cognitive bias it's a mental shortcut
essentially your brain doesn't want to
process through facts over and over
again instead it wants to assume certain
facts are in place and just jump right
to the conclusion it saves energy it
saves megabytes
so what joe what joe or joe rogan i feel
weird calling him joe i don't know him
but what joe identified on his own mr
rogan what mr rogan identified on his
own yeah
was his own cognitive loop
and then he immediately grew suspicious
of that loop
that is a super powerful tool that is
something that most people never become
self-actualized enough to realize that
they have a cognitive loop let alone
questioning their own cognitive loop so
that was
when it came to this topic specifically
that was just something that i thought
was really powerful because
you learned to not just not trust
yourself on the record
after he drinks one whiskey all that
goes out i think that was just in that
moment in time
like you know uh
brilliance a moment
because i i think he still is uh
you know um
is
he's definitely one of the things that
inspires me about joe is how open-minded
he is how curious he is he refuses to
let sort of the conformity and the
conventions
of any one community including the
scientific community be a kind of uh
thing that limits his curiosity of
asking what if
uh it's like the the whole it's entirely
possible i think that's a beautiful
thing it actually represents
what uh the best of science is that
childlike curiosity but so it's good to
sort of balance those two things but
then you have to wake up to it like
is is this is there a chance this is
true or do i just really want it to be
true and that like that hot girl that
talks to you overseas yeah
yeah
for a brief moment
there's there's actually a deeper
explanation for it that i'll tell you
off the mic that uh perhaps a lot of
people can kind of figure out anyway
just to take it one step further because
i love this stuff personally i love pink
i love pink matter stuff
and your interview with jack barski
jack's good a good friend of mine a good
dude incredible person yeah in your
conversation with jack barsky
you guys uh he started talking to you
about
how his recruiters were feeding back to
him his own beliefs his own opinions
about himself how smart he was how good
he was how uniquely qualified he was
that's all pink matter manipulation
feeding right back to the person what
they already think of themselves is a
way to get them to invest and trust you
faster because obviously you value them
for all the right reasons because that's
how they see themselves so that that
loop
that
the kgb was using with jack
jack did not wake up to that loop at the
time he woke up to it later
so it's it's happens to all of us we're
all in a loop
it's just whether it's about
oat milk or whether it's about aliens or
whether it's about
you know the democrats trying to take
your guns whatever it is everybody's in
a loop and we've got to wake up to to
ask ourselves just like you said
is it true or do we just really want it
to be true and until you ask yourself
that question you're just one of the
masses trapped in the loop
yeah that's the that's the really the
the nietzsche
gaze into the abyss it's a dangerous
thing it's that's the path to insanity
is to ask that question you want to be
doing it carefully but it's also the
place where you can truly discover
something fundamental about this world
that people don't understand and then
that and lay the groundwork for
progress
scientific
cultural all that kind of stuff
you